there steve kaufman here
it's a bit of a miserable day here in
vancouver it's cloudy and overcast and i
have a cold so
don't be surprised if i break out into a
cough here
but i thought i would follow up my
recent videos
where i talked about frustrations that
we sometimes feel in language learning
uh and talk a little bit about how do we
know if we're progressing in a language
i want to talk about that subject and
then if i have time or maybe in the in a
subsequent video
i'll answer a question that i received
uh from a teacher an english teacher in
japan who asked me you know
given that the role of the teacher is to
motivate primarily to motivate the
student and given that there are so many
resources available today
just what should be the role of a
teacher in a classroom
now i'm going to offer my opinions on
that probably in the next video based on
never having been a teacher in a
classroom but
based on my experience as a learner
both in the classroom and outside the
classroom but before we get to that
let's talk about this business of
how do we know if we're making progress
first of all the simple answer is we
know
i know when i'm able to say more things
or when i understand more
uh in a language
the problem is
that the improvement is so slow
that often
we go for long stretches without feeling
that we've made any progress
so
what should we do
and
you know i mentioned in one of my
earlier
previous videos about these sort of
technical terms that are used in the
you know
second language acquisition
industry terms like interlanguage
which say that as you are learning
another language you will obviously be
influenced by your native language and
therefore you will continue to produce
patterns
or even pronunciation or use words
or sayings
that come from your native language and
that this will influence you when you
speak another language
and i made the point that of course
that's true
and i know many people for example who
speak english very well in particular
swedes who are very good at english and
they will always use certain swedish
construction constructions like instead
of saying there are many people
in china they'll say it is many people
in china that's a very swedish
construction
uh
and they'll you know their esses or
their i was listening we were listening
with my wife to
a swedish commentator on a golf program
and you can tell that she's swedish she
is influenced by her native language in
use of words in structure in
pronunciation
but to me that doesn't mean that she's
speaking interlanguage she is speaking
english
and she
is probably at least the announcer not
the people that i know
i'm referring now to swedish speaking
people who speak english very very well
they don't need to get beyond that
they're all ready to do it doing very
very well
if they wanted to
focus on some of these expressions that
are a little bit swedish they probably
could get rid of them if they wanted to
or maybe they can't it really doesn't
matter they're very good at
communicating in english the problem is
not when we get to that stage where we
kind of let our shirt tails hang out
every now and again as an anglicism
slips into our russian or french or or
whatever the problem is when we're
starting out and for a good long period
we have the feeling that we're forever
unable to say what we want we don't
quite understand the movie we don't
quite understand what people are saying
and we sort of feel that we're not
making any progress and i refer to this
earlier
when i said you know don't get
frustrated just focus on doing things
that you enjoy doing okay but then if we
do focus on doing things that we enjoy
doing how do we know that we're making
progress
okay
to me
i like
the word count now i know that's quite
controversial and it's very much central
to what we do at link
but i know for example in in czech i've
been at it since august
my goal by the way when i start into a
language is not
immediately to speak it
because i think that's very difficult
and i and i'm not convinced that it's a
good thing to try to do because you may
in fact if you spend a lot of time
speaking
improperly you may ingrain those habits
and you know to me language learning is
about
two things in a way it's about
repetition
and it's about stimulating the brain
with new things so you've got to have a
mixture of repetition and a mixture of
new stimulating interesting things so
you're mixing the two but if you're
doing too much repetition with a very
narrow
vocabulary base
and with improper structure and improper
pronunciation that's what you're getting
used to that's what you're hearing
similarly if we sit in a classroom say
we're japanese and we sit in the
classroom with other japanese people who
are learning english
most of the japanese that we hear in the
classroom
is what the other non-native speakers
are saying so i'm not a great fan of
that i would far rather
listen to a native speaker i might have
to just take this briefly and see who it
is hello
can i call you back i'm in the middle of
a video
you're in the office
okay bye
yeah so
there's an interruption there
uh
so uh what i was saying was
that so i don't like being in a
classroom because i'm hearing and i'm
ingraining and i'm
basically
repeating
uh a form of the language that i don't
want
so
we want to repeat and we want novelty
and to me that's listening and reading
okay but how do i know that i'm getting
anywhere well i know because i've done
it so often i know for example in the
case of my russian
that as i listened more and more and as
i read more and more slowly i started to
be able to speak better and i then
started to speak more and more but what
was my gauge that i was actually making
progress well that gauge is the number
of words that i know and that's why we
make that the main metric
at link
now
it's kind of like a leading indicator
you have to do a lot of other things you
can't study these words from wordless
you have to learn them through a lot of
listening and reading you also should
save phrases but the one easy thing
to measure the sort of gordy and not is
the number of words you know now people
are going to say well you know how do
you know if you know them you know them
passively you can't use them i don't
care
if i can understand them in a context
i'm happy because my goal is to
understand
and i know that if i build up my ability
to understand that's a very solid base
from which to start speaking if your
ability to speak gets ahead of your
ability to understand you'll be in for
some difficult times because you'll say
something and you won't understand what
people say back to you now in czech i've
been added since august link tells me
that i know 20 000 words i don't really
know 20 000 words
but i know that two months ago i only
know i only knew say ten thousand so now
i know twenty thousand so i know with
every day as i'm continuing to work at
it i am increasing my vocabulary and i
also know as i download text from
czech newspapers on the web that i
understand more and more of it that
there's more and more of these words
that in fact i do know albeit passively
so to me
a very good measure
of whether or not we're progressing
is this number of words that you know
uh because it means that your
comprehension is increasing whether in
fact it's 20 000 or because czech is a
very inflected language it equates to 5
000 words in english or whatever it
doesn't matter it's not for bragging
rights it's in order to
demonstrate to yourself that in fact you
are continuing to progress and if you
continue to progress and your vocabulary
you know the words known number
continues to increase you will
understand better and better you'll read
more material you'll as you're reading
you'll come across some of the words
that you really know and some of them
you more or less know and you'll be
constantly reading and exposing yourself
to the language and your comprehension
will improve and that to me is the
number one thing when you have a strong
sense of understanding you know ability
to understand the language then you
start speaking now there are people who
say well you know i can read very well
but i can't speak
and i always ask them i've had this
discussion many times and i said oh you
read very well so then for example are
you comfortable reading a novel
would you go and grab a novel people say
immigrants in canada say you know i
can't speak very well but i read very
well we chinese read very well like you
often hear that
with a group of say 50 chinese people in
a lecture once i said so how many people
here willingly pick up a novel and read
it just like that as something that they
enjoy doing nobody
well
to read well you got to enjoy reading
it's not that you can pick your way
through a short uh you know article
you're gonna be able to read books and
similarly with listening
uh do you enjoy audiobooks you know do
you understand most of what's on the
radio this is where you got to get to in
your comprehension to do that you need
words
because the biggest thing is if you if
you're missing a word now i know we we
also want to learn phrases and so forth
but phrases are composed of words if
very often and i know also that uh
eighty percent of any context uh
consists of the 2000 most frequently
used words but it's the other 20
that determine the meaning so
measuring the words you know and and
having you know a way of staying on top
of the fact that you are constantly
increasing your vocabulary through these
input-based activities to my mind is a
good indicator that you are improving
and when you have a certain level of of
uh vocabulary and i'm not there yet in
my check i'd like to have another 10 000
words and do a lot more listening
and then i'm going to start speaking
more i've spoken a couple of times it's
been very difficult but i'm quite
convinced that some other people who
maybe start speaking earlier will be
ahead of me it's a bit of a sort of
tortoise and hair situation the hair
will jump ahead of me they'll be able to
say more things and check
very early but in the long run after six
months i'm convinced that i will be able
to do more with my check
in terms of reading listening having
intelligent conversations with people on
a variety of subjects
so
there's a quickie then on
and that's a theme that i've i've talked
about before
and that is you know now i've got to
find where is it
i've got to find my cursor uh
yeah words keep up your word count and
you'll get there that is the as i've
described before it's the basically the
little uh mechanical rabbit at the dog
race it's something that keeps you going
so
thank you for listening oh and i should
add that obviously these words have to
be gleaned through things that you enjoy
doing so listening to music if you like
in songs or listening to
um audiobooks or reading
you know books or articles but
constantly pushing yourself a little
further and further ahead and increasing
your known word count thank you for
listening bye for now